hey everybody's Jessie and today we're
gonna do some security work for our file
uploader so we we built the uploader
using node and we didn't even do any
type of security at first we just got it
working and left it alone for a while
now I want to go back to it and I want
to white make a whitelist for the
different file types that were in accept
set a maximum file size and we'll see
what else we could put on here that's
that's reasonable
for for security and if you all have any
suggestions or experience with node and
file uploads let me know you can check
out the code our server dot J's file in
the repository the link is in the
description so I've changed it slightly
from from what's in the repo so I
haven't committed any of this yet I'm
doing this all on a separate branch and
what's the name the file type check is
the branch name so that that branch is
committed to the repository but there's
a little bit that hasn't been committed
yet so you'll be able to see most of
this file and I'll show you the parts
that have changed yesterday I mentioned
that I was having some trouble with the
server and it wasn't working and I had
an idea of what it was and it turns out
I was actually right about what the
problem was I just missed a step so it
did have to do with that home page in
package.json that was added to give us
support for github pages but so what I
had done and I mentioned yesterday was I
took out that part of package JSON the
home page
part and then I tried to run the server
again well with the step that I missed
was building so I didn't rebuild before
I've tried to run it so it was still
using the old build that had the
homepage set from package.json so once I
rebuilt after removing it everything
works so for now we're gonna leave out
that homepage we're getting to the point
where we'll probably have a version on a
real server soon so we won't we won't
need the github pages version when we
have that we can just link to that so
for now if you I guess if we really
wanted to we could probably keep one
branch with that in there but I don't
know let me know I don't know if
anybody's going to the github pages page
or not if if a lot of people are using
it then maybe I'll make another branch
otherwise I'll just wait a little while
until I get the server up and running
for this all right so I'm gonna check
the live chat quickly say hello okay so
have a question so Andy says Dee's
create react app for all your projects
and the answer is no i you i also use
next jazz for some projects if I need
server-side rendering I use next if I
don't need server-side rendering I
usually use create react app Ivan create
react app I don't really know for sure
but it just it seems this is gonna seem
weird because it makes a lot of
decisions for you but it seems like I
have more freedom with create react app
in terms of what I want to use like for
instance I can use react router Redux
I'm sure there's a way to do that with
next
but next comes with routing new things
built-in so I experiment with more
things when I use create react app so I
don't I'm not sure that that's a great
reason to choose one or the other but
that's what that's what I've been doing
and it's nice to try out different
different things
alright so Matteo is joining us from
from Italy for the first time live
welcome it's a I'm glad you could you
could join us Brett said first time on
the livestream as well awesome so we
have at least two first-timers so
welcome that's exciting
alright so first thing we'll do is let
me go over briefly a pull request that
we got actually within I think we got it
within the last hour and I was able to
merge that and that's part of the the
master branch now so well we got a lot
more so john s is the first time a
metamer not sure how to say that is
first time to so awesome that's really
exciting sometimes I wonder if I said
the same people watching or if I do get
new people so alright ones first time
Christian first time wow this is really
cool I'm excited
alright so since there's so many
first-timers let me take a few seconds
just to explain now I'm you may it's
maybe your first time live and you may
have watched this before so sorry if
this is a repeat but the way this this
show works so basically you're watching
me do my everyday job I'm a front-end
developer at a university Sebastian says
it's his first time yeah yeah so my goal
this is not really a tutorial the
goal is just to give you an idea of what
things are like for me I don't really
know if I have kind of an average
experience as a developer or not I've
usually worked alone and that's why I
kind of felt the need for something like
this because I don't really know what
it's like for other developers I've
always been freelance or now in my
current role I'm the only front-end
developer there is you know there's one
other person that does a lot of
development work but we usually work on
separate projects so I don't really have
a team so I thought it would be cool to
just share what I'm doing and it's kind
of built into this team now where we
have a lot of different people
contributing to the project and helping
out in the live chat so I try to keep it
kind of this as interactive as possible
where I take your suggestions and a lot
of your suggestions get incorporated I
learn a lot from you all hopefully you
all can learn something from me or at
least learn from my mistakes which I
make frequently and I don't obviously
it's live I don't edit anything out so
the format is I give a little
introduction a review pull requests and
then we get to the code will code for
usually about an hour maybe sometimes
more every 25 minutes I take a five
minute break to check the live chat and
answer questions and then at the end
whatever questions are left over I just
take that time to answer all the
questions usually I can get to all of
them
it's very rare maybe like two or three
times it's happened that I couldn't get
to all the questions so so don't worry
about putting any questions you have in
there be patient if I don't get to them
at first though if there's a lot of
questions in there I may not get to
until the end but I'll do my best to get
to get to everything the recording of
this will be available on the free code
camp Channel
just a few minutes after the stream ends
ok so I think that's all the normal
stuff that that I need to say about the
stream so
[Applause]
I see there are some questions and so
I'm gonna get to those I'm gonna start
into the code and then I'll get to those
on my first break so just tank hang in
there a bit also there's a lot of really
knowledgeable people in the live chat so
sometimes they get to the questions
before I do and give great answers
better answers than I could could give
so make sure you check if you ask you a
question you know keep an eye on a live
chat and you'll probably get some some
really good answers ok so first things
first
let me just show you this pull request
and I'm getting it ready on my other
screens and then I'll pull it over ok so
this is the pull request we get so Thank
You Sebastian and you can see here you
can check it out pull request number 53
if you want to see the files to change
and everything but basically added some
padding and we had talked about that
maybe last week sometime or earlier I
think it was last week at a page title
had some consistency with the way we
were using map from lodash and corrected
my spelling for the SVG and we I wasted
so much time because of a typo but if
you was it last week yeah so really nice
pull request Thank You Sebastian also I
forgot to mention this yesterday and I
think it'll be really helpful for a lot
of you it certainly will be for me and I
have no idea how I forgot to mention
this because it was so awesome
but as kind of a note on the end of the
description of Matt's pool request
yesterday he added some stuff about
Redux he actually made a repository all
about it's basically just an example of
using redux and it's really well
commented so if you're interested in
learning Redux check that out you can
the links here and I I forked it as well
so it's it's on my github profile too
but really really cool and useful I had
mentioned last week that I was having
trouble with Redux on the Udacity react
nanodegree course and Matt last week had
said it had offered to help and then
without me even asking just provided so
much so I really appreciate that and I
haven't had time to work on that course
yet but I'm gonna work on it probably at
some point this week hopefully I'll have
some time on the weekend as well and I'm
definitely going to go through that
repository and you know learn as much as
I can okay let's get started I do want
to apologize to anyone who was watching
the Instagram stream yesterday which if
you're not familiar with that my on
Instagram I have a second stream at the
same time as this one and you can see my
face if you're interested in that but
it's just kind of a like novelty type of
fun thing so but anyway I had the wrong
camera on so everybody was looking at my
desk instead of my face for the first
few minutes so sorry about that I just I
didn't even notice it until a few
minutes in
but today the streams good how-to right
off the bat alright so here's my here's
what I've added so let me show you what
I brought in so I brought in
this file type package so with this
package at least for my understanding
what it's supposed to do is read a
stream read the just enough of bytes to
know what type the file is and so I
thought yeah definitely I want that but
then I couldn't get it to work probably
because I was trying to read files that
were not being streamed in then I found
on Stack Overflow someone trying to do a
similar thing and you can just check
right from formidable which is what
we're using to handle or form data you
can just check the file type now here's
the thing I'm not sure about on the
formidable documentation it mentions
that doing it this way so just getting
the file type is not it says it's the
file type is it as reported by the
client let me see I have the
documentation up on my other screen I
want to read you with what it says
exactly
type it says the M IME type of this file
according to the uploading client so I
wasn't sure what that was saying exactly
is the and here was my worry was if that
is is that being sent client-side could
that be faked would it be more reliable
to try to get that file type plug-in
working because that's actually reading
the bytes of the file instead so let me
know what you think about that if you
have any experience with that I think
I'm gonna go with this for now and maybe
try to do a little bit more research
I've already read through a lot of stuff
without without really finding a
definitive answer but for now I'll I'll
try this out and hopefully this works
and you know I don't want I'm not like
really really worried about malicious
files and things
I mean I'm reasonably worried about it
but it wouldn't be the end of the world
this is going to be on its own separate
server not connected to anything else
that has to do with any of our sites or
databases or anything so even if it were
to happen which I'm gonna try my best to
make sure it doesn't happen
but even if something were to happen
it's going to be contained which is good
but I'd still like to do it the best way
possible if I can so if you know of any
resources that I can use to learn more
about this you know please please let me
know alright so we're going to go along
with with this so right before I started
this dream I just added this in here
from the stack overflow question and
what I'm doing is I've just created a
constant called type
and actually copied and pasted and say
here we go I wanted it to be called file
type
okay so file type equals this this is
from formidable that we can go file dot
type now that will give us something
like image slash in PNG right jpg
something so that that's what it'll
it'll give us but I don't want to have
to type image slash for everything to
check so that's where we're doing the
split in the pop so that it returns
something like this which is a little
bit easier to check so all basically
most of this if not all of it
well not all of it I did change a bit
but most of it is just copy and pasted
right from Stack Overflow and for the
most part unedited so I figure we'll try
it out and I'm gonna upload some files
and see if this will actually work
basically what we're doing is checking
for the file type if it is one of these
types then we'll go ahead with this
otherwise we'll console.log incorrect
file type and we'll also make sure we
check the uploads directory to see what
is actually been uploaded and let me
yeah I definitely want to
I want to delete that because that that
one's going to be the unsupported file
type all right so I've there's not
really any sense pulling the the site up
on the screen right now because all I'm
gonna do is just hit hit the submit
button
but I'm will look at the output here and
this is what we really want to look at
so let me make sure I'm uploading
something with a different file site
alright so I'm just uploading a bunch of
things with one dot xcf file whoa an
error occurred let's see
maybe I didn't hit save
I thought I fixed that all right let's
hit save and chat again there we go
alright so let's see what happened okay
so once it got to here its we see it
says incorrect file type and then we do
we get a message we still got a message
that it's uploaded but it should not
have actually uploaded that's right and
it did not upload so we will have to I
guess we could probably change this so
that it checks the same thing I'm not
sure that it really matters whether or
not we have this anyway we're not this
is nice for testing but we're not really
gonna see this for most of the time so
this will probably get removed at some
point anyway so I'm not too worried
about that right now but we can confirm
this is probably too small for most of
you to see but there are no dot x CF
files in the uploads folder
all right and I forgot to start my
Pomodoro timer all right I'm gonna do
just a ten-minute right now since I
forgot to start it and after the ten
minutes I'll do my five-minute break and
I'll go back to the live chat since
we're about 20 minutes in anyway that
that'll be close to what it would have
been if I would have remembered to start
it all right so that's the kind of the
first layer that I wanted to do
obviously this needs cleaned up we need
to add more things to this list just
figure out what I want on this list and
and add it all I'm sure there's a better
way to do it than this this is going to
get really long and let's see it would
be nice to also do the same type of
validation client-side is to let the
user know if they're trying to upload a
file that's the wrong type so we may not
get to that today but I just wanted to
mention that that that's that's going to
be a good thing to do otherwise people
are going to upload a file thinking that
it worked
and it's not going to work and that
could result in some confusion we don't
want to rely on the client side stuff we
definitely want the server side as well
and let's go with let's try to limit the
file size now so formidable comes with
let me try to find there we go
I'm going to bring over the
documentation on formidable so we can
all make sure we're all looking at the
same thing so
sighs so this we can get the file size
right from here there's also an option
so we can also limit the fields side so
I'm not I guess I'm not super worried
about the fields but there's already a
default max in here so I'm not gonna
change this right now I'm okay with this
default max right and this says accept
file so this doesn't really have
anything to do with the files it's just
the fields so the defaults fine but what
we want to do is check the file size and
then reject any files let me think what
a reasonable sizes I'll just put just
any size in there for now just to test
it make sure you have it working and
then I'm gonna check to see what what
size limit I have in place currently for
the the older version of this that's
live right now and I'll probably stick
with the same size limitation since you
know users are already familiar with
that the other thing that I'll mention
why well it's in my head is we're gonna
want to change the file names so as far
as I understand security wise the reason
you'd want to change the file names is
potentially so like we want users to be
able to access these files right so I
want people I want to be able to access
the files on people in my department to
be able to access the files on the
server by the link in case for some
reason the files don't get transferred
over to our project management system so
that folder where the files are is going
to be accessible so I don't want
somebody uploading something and then
trying to run it so we're going to
change the file name alright so they
won't they won't be able to just type
the file name the day enter in and run
it they'll have no idea what the file
name is that file name is going to get
sent the new file name will get sent in
the email that's going to go to our
project manager so she'll be able to
click on those links the user is going
to get sent the old file names just so
that they can confirm that those were
the files that they intended to send but
they're not going to be able to click
the link and check their files out so
that should you know prevent some
malicious activity I suppose and correct
me if I'm wrong but that that was my
understanding of the benefit of changing
file names and I guess there's also a
benefit of people not over writing files
if they happen to upload a file with the
same name it would overwrite the file
that was in there so this way files are
going to have a unique name and you
won't have you know either of the
problems that I just mentioned alright
but first let's check out where the file
size alright so I'm just going to
console.log file size just to make sure
that it is working
I think it will I really don't have any
reason to doubt that this would work but
rather check it out now okay
all right so it's not working in there
probably because we have it in file
begin let's see
all right so we need some other way to
check the file size
I mean obviously if I put it here then
we should get the real file size right
so we're getting that here but at that
point the files already been uploaded
and we want to stop it from even being
uploaded
it seems like I'm missing something
that's really obvious here right there
should be a way to limit the file size
yeah I think I still have yeah I still
have the stackoverflow question where I
got the the previous code from as well
I'm interested to see how they're
handling that
so it looks like they're not they're not
checking size at all all right let me
check the latch act quickly
and I'm about to the end anyway so I
want to see if anyone's put anything in
here about about our problem
okay
all right so looks like you have some
suggestions so thanks John Hanson
suggested sanitizing fields and suggest
github.com dome purify so I'll check
that out thank you for that let me let
me go ahead and do my five minutes now
so we'll take a break from the code for
five minutes and I'm going to answer
questions in the live chat then we'll
come back and try to figure out what to
do about this file size and actually
maybe I'll explain when we come back
I'll explain a little bit about how
we're uploading files in the first place
because if you didn't catch the the
episode whenever we did that then you
may may be a little bit confused if
you've never handled file uploads and
node
makalah says I'm of you I'm a huge a s
user but I like Jesse that's cool I
really I appreciate you saying that
that's cool
Christian says this is pretty nice thank
you
thank you I appreciate you saying that I
Abdul Azeez says I joined free code camp
last week and I'm excited awesome
awesome
glad you glad you joined I hope you're
making it through the the exercises and
everything and feel free to ask any
questions
Christian says the idea about the team
sounds fantastic yeah I actually the
team thing came as kind of a surprise to
me so well the first thing was I didn't
know if anybody would even want to watch
this at all
and the first week or so I had there
were maybe like two streams where I had
no one watched at all and then I had
just maybe like one or two people that
watched consistently and then whenever I
got invited to do this for the free code
camp Channel I got a lot more viewers
you know just because of how well-known
free code camp is at that point it
really started it started to pick up and
feel more like a team when people
started contributing to the project both
from pool requests and from suggestions
and the live chat from you know messages
on Twitter and things so now that team
is just kind of grown and yeah I can't
take credit for planning that at all it
just it happened it's been it's been
great and I've learned so much from the
suggestions and all the code that has
been contributed because obviously I go
through it all I can't just merge stuff
in without looking at it and to get when
I go through it all I have to try my
best to understand it all as well so I
know my my coding has gotten at least I
think it's gotten a lot better maybe one
day I'll go back and
watch some of the first dreams and
compare and maybe you all have seen some
sort of change if you've been watching
from the beginning but yeah that's been
a really really pleasant surprise
having you know this community now
Sergey asks what do you think about
react Redux and rxjs I I like them
i I think I really enjoy working with
react Redux is confusing to me at this
point I guess the big picture concepts
of Redux are not that confusing like I
get the flow of everything but the
actual implementation of particularly
trying to get data from an API and then
put it in the component right now I'm
getting the problem where my components
are rendering before the data comes in
and then they don't they don't ever get
the correct data so I'm missing
something somewhere along the way so I
don't know if it's in my reducers or my
actions or what so that's just kind of
the the thing that I'm working with
right now that's confusing to me I'm not
really sure you know how to troubleshoot
and the best way to go about that so I'm
not to that point I think at least for
me when I work with something new a lot
of what I'm doing at first is just
trying to adapt what other people have
done without fully understanding
everything after you work with it for a
long time is after I work with it for a
long time I get to the point where I can
start doing my own thing more at that
point then it's it gets a lot easier
when something goes wrong but I'm at
that first stage right now where since I
don't fully understand everything when
something goes wrong then
it's really hard to figure out why it
went wrong and sometimes you know I'll
change something without even realizing
you know what it does but I mean that's
how you learn it's just it's this second
project for the Udacity course is taking
a lot longer than I had hoped it would
take just because of that because of
having to troubleshoot what I'm doing
with Redux so anyway don't know how
great of an answer that was to your
question but let's just I guess a little
bit of what I think about react and
redux all right so I'm gonna go back to
the code now I didn't make it through
everything that's currently in the live
chat but I'll come back to it I'm
actually I'm gonna write down the
timestamp for where I left off
so I don't forget and I'll be able to
get back to it more quickly on our next
break so let me start up our 25 minute
timer and as I mentioned a few minutes
ago let me just take a moment just to go
through what what we're doing so we have
a form so we have this form and when we
hit submit the form goes to our uploads
path and so everything within so we're
using Express so we're using nodejs
right which is JavaScript running on the
server side we're using Express with
that okay and a bunch of other stuff to
help us make handling forms easier so in
particular formidable we're doing some
things with that so we're using send
grid to send mail okay but you know
basically the main thing we're doing is
we're listening for for that uploads
let me see where it's at I lost it for
when something comes in to that uploads
directory and then we're going to do
some stuff if that happens so in
particular we're using formidable to
handle that form data all right so that
that helps take care of some things for
us and then well particularly what we're
working on right now is what do we do
with the files so on file begins so when
we varied the first time we start to get
a file and we're uploading it right to
our upload directory with with a certain
file name and right now we're just
keeping the same name and and that's our
file uploader basically so that's what
we started with and it works I mean down
here we're just console logging the file
name down here we're making an array of
the files because we use that later on
when we want to send things to different
places so we're this is where we're
getting all the values of all the other
inputs and we're creating a string out
of all those inputs and adding breaks in
between it and then that way we can send
this data in a more readable format and
then down here we're doing some sending
emails right so we're sending that
string and we're also sending file names
and then we're also sending some things
to our project management system which
is called rike so we're sending that
same data that we send the email but in
addition we're also sending the actual
files so that's pretty much everything
that's going on in our server dot J's
file so if you haven't seen one of these
or worked with one before I said what it
might look confusing it is it's
JavaScript
and it's using a lot of different
packages from from NPM but you know the
basics of what's going on I think it or
not it's not that hard to understand so
hopefully you know that was a decent
overview for you to understand the
context of what we're doing and now
we'll get back to ok file size that's
what we want so we tried putting getting
the file size on file begin that's not
gonna work because the file has just
begun being loaded being uploaded and
it's showing up as zero what we want is
to get the file size let's see
let's get the fuss re I just I just got
distracted I looked over at the lab chat
and saw someone Christian s are you in
are you Jesse in San Francisco I am NOT
in San Francisco I am in Ohio right now
house quite far away from San Francisco
but I like San Francisco it's a really
nice City I like that there are very few
traffic lights and a lot of stop signs I
think that's really cool and all the
streets are in like an alphabetical grid
and in numbered so you really can't get
lost there's a lot of other really cool
things about San Francisco but I just I
that was just really cool to me anyway I
guess I'm gonna have to do some some
googling here quickly see
all right so here's my I don't know if
you actually want to see my googling but
just in case here it is so not bad we
got some stuff it's pretty old so let's
go for past year so cynical edition okay
yeah this is yeah this is what I want
looks like some people are using jQuery
I don't want jQuery we're not using
jQuery all right well let's see what we
have these first two
I mean I'd rather this is all client
side of course I think we should have a
client side check but I'd rather have
both the server side and client side
check yeah so maybe I should be more
specific in node
okay this see so we are we we are we do
have FS already
okay so this person is trying to do the
same thing that I want to do want to
check it without actually uploading it
the state class will not upload the file
as I think all right well let's check
that documentation then all right so
we're checking the documentation for
getting the file size
mmm
all right yes we can try this
[Applause]
all right so let's see what what did
all right I'm gonna move this over to my
other screen so I can keep looking at it
while we
while we test it out
all right let me see someone just asked
in a live chat to see the website so
here's the at least one page in the site
I'm eating some suggestions here and the
live chat so let me check them out
oh okay so Brett's saying to use the on
progress and and check it like that okay
cool
hey Phillip how's it going - Phillips in
the live chat says it's been a while
yeah it's been a while hopefully
everything is going well with you
welcome back
alright so that's always formidable here
we go alright so let me show you what I
think it's down here what we're talking
about okay so we were checking this
we're gonna use this to check on our
file size and see how we're gonna do
this
well let's copy it first and play around
with it okay
alright let's just put this in here for
now and let's console.log
all right so let's just check out what
we get when we do this so this should
the documentation says for each chunk of
data that's downloaded this should give
us values okay so submit that awesome
all right great so we are getting
received and expected nice so really as
long as we know the expected I guess we
could roll right away we could rule out
a file if the expected amount of data is
more than our cap and then we did
further check it to make sure that the
received amount of data is under the cap
so I don't know if it's possible but
maybe the expected data it could be
incorrect and file the real file size is
much bigger so I can see value in
checking both
all right awesome so thank you Brett
that was definitely what we needed all
right so now let's just figure out how
we're going to hook this up into what
we're currently doing the the easiest
thing would just be to put this this
form on right in here I don't really
think that'll work but it's it's such an
easy thing that I think it's worthwhile
to just try it even though I have just
really small hopes of it actually
working but let's give it a shot hey
well we didn't get an error there which
is nice
that's interesting it did it actually
work
I was compared mm-hmm
okay
maybe that did work
I I did not think it would work but if
it did that's great
see so it's always worthwhile to just
try something especially if it if it
doesn't really take that long to test it
and know if it works or not all right so
I think this works just like this which
makes it a lot easier so what we can do
then is now obviously there's always
time to refactor so if you're looking at
my code during this and thinking like
what is he doing
certainly I'm definitely I'm open for
well number one for me refactoring but
also if anybody else really wants to
refactor you know this is available on
github for pool requests and I
appreciate that so for now I guess I'll
leave this logs in and let's put let's
see
if bytes expected or just I don't know
what we want to set the limit as I want
some of these to not go through so
respected it's greater than just cut
this down oops
I'm here or fights received
then we will actually upload and let's
also
[Music]
yeah we'll be able to see what gets
uploaded so let's save that and deletes
I think we can just delete let's delete
everything out of here then it'll be
really obvious what makes it in whoa so
[Music]
there we go
okay all right so everything's deleted
now and we'll be able to see what gets
uploaded let me see it may not upload
anything I'm not sure what all these
sizes are but yeah let's see
actually not I'm looking at this
it's really odd that each one of these
files is exactly the same size that
makes me think that something's wrong so
let's give it a shot
okay it's alright cool so nothing was
uploaded which is what we expected I
definitely want to see though what size
these files really are
so I'm gonna try to find these files see
which ones are trying to upload activity
for
yeah something's wrong because these
files are definitely different sizes
all right so what's going on
so even when we had it let's
double-check back to this the first time
I want to check the first time we had
this where it was outside of the other
function
there we go all right so we had for that
first file 21 okay so it was already
happening then
hmm
all right
let me think about this I'm not exactly
sure what the problem is
it's which which should be happening
it's this let's let's look at the
documentation it doesn't say much about
it I did it doesn't say that this is for
every file individually is it possible
that this is for everything in the form
being sent
yes
all right well I know I guess we can
test this let's remove one of these
files so we're gonna go from day for to
day seven instead of day eight now if it
was giving us the total of all of this
it should be different right otherwise
if it's something else going on
like for instance maybe it's just
telling us the value for this first one
over and over again then it should still
be the same
all right
okay all right so we got a different
value now all right I do want to test
one thing and my test was a bit flawed
so on the off chance that it was
actually giving us the value of the last
one over and over again let's do it
again where we take the first one off
but keep the last one and see what we
get
okay and that's a different value as
well so what what it seems like is
happening is that this is not this is
not the value
I mean
yeah this makes sense yeah I think this
is giving us the total bytes received
not per file if you notice and I didn't
notice this before is that this this
number keeps going up even regardless of
what's being said here when this file
actually it's uploaded it just keeps
going up and up and up so at first I
thought for some reason that it was
restarting every time and I just was not
paying enough attention but this is
giving us the total for everything if
that's the best we can do that's not
terrible we could just set a max which I
mean how would that be different than
setting a limit to the number of files
and then a max per file it really
wouldn't be I guess it doesn't
necessarily matter one way or another
you know if we set a one megabyte limit
and a 10 file limit or if we just set a
10 megabyte total limit it still still
gonna be the same I guess it would be
less confusing to the user if we could
set a per file limit but if we can't
this will still work so my timer did go
off that was a really fast 25 minutes so
let me go back to the live chat and I
will scroll up to
let's see
I'm going to scroll up to the point in
the live chat we're in Eastern time it
was eight minutes after two so I'm about
an hour behind in a live chat and let's
try to answer some more questions
Brett says learned yarn from you Jesse
awesome cool although now people were
telling me to use the latest version of
NPM instead of yarn but I've seen mixed
things about that some people were
saying yarn is still faster I don't
really know I probably won't change for
this project I'm used to the yarn
commands now so maybe for a future
project I'll try it
Igor's asks what's the point of this app
basically the main point of the app is
to allow users to submit requests for
work to my department so I work in the
marketing department and we do a lot of
different things both print design and
writing and videos photography and
websites so people will be able to use
this form it'll send all the data
directly to our project management
system and from there our project
manager can assign the project to the
the correct people it's also a resource
where people can download things so
logos university logos and the the guide
for for writing I guess there's a
writing guide for official guidelines
for university correspondence and things
so there's some other things as well
there
oh it seems the audio was cutting out
for Mandela effect conference so it
looks like it's not cutting out for
anybody else so I'm guessing then it's
not something on my end so sorry about
that I'm not really sure if I could do
anything about it
get success boy you've made me love
coding love you brother I'm pretty
grateful to you oh that's awesome thank
you so much for saying that
I really really appreciate that that's
that's cool I'm glad sometimes I worry
that my streams get boring especially
when I can't figure out what to do but
if I've made you love coding then I must
be doing something right so that's
awesome
it's
Brett says Brett was having a
conversation with someone else it was
also from San Francisco but he mentioned
in that conversation that I like Jesse
strange because he goes through the
bumps in the road yeah my streams are
very bumpy sometimes that was the point
I I definitely it's intentional that I
don't prepare beforehand for two reasons
one of them is a very selfish lazy
reason and one of them is a useful
reason the lazy reason is if I don't
prepare beforehand then I don't have to
take time to prepare right so it's I can
do these videos without without as much
work which is kind of necessary if I if
I had to pre-record videos and edit and
do everything then there's no way I
could do this everyday for a couple
hours but the the more useful reason at
least for all of you is I wanted you all
to see what it's like for me and how
often I make mistakes and have to work
through that because the pre-recorded
tutorial videos that are out there are
really awesome and I benefited greatly
from them but you get the feeling
especially when I was starting out you
get the feeling like everybody else
knows what they're doing and you don't
because you you know I messed up a lot
and they never mess up and realistically
they have time to edit I mean I'm sure
that you know five-minute video takes a
lot longer than five minutes to do
because their mistakes but those get
edited out you don't see those so I
really wanted you all to be able to see
the mistakes so I was a little bit
nervous at everyone thinking that I was
a noob because I make so many mistakes
but I've gotten over that now and in
fact no one calls me a noob you are very
understanding of the mistakes and I
think that's that's part of the
uniqueness of this of this stream
is uniqueness a word I'm not sure it
just sounded weird when I said it okay
I'm gonna I'm actually really close to
being at the bottom of the live chat so
I'm just going to take another few
seconds and look at this if there's any
questions before I go back to the code
Jordan says hello from Tennessee hey
how's it going I've got relatives in
Tennessee and who else Patrick Patrick's
in Tennessee too right yeah
okay I'm glad I looked down because
there's a lot in here talking about what
was just going on so it seems like you
all figured out what was going on before
I did
that's just great until 2:30 then not so
great without sugar yeah that's uh
that's kind of what I was getting at
when I was talking about refactoring is
this better get at it in later sometimes
when I'm really trying to do things I
just fall back on the very basics of
JavaScript just to get it to work
because I know I'm comfortable with the
basics and I don't want to be
troubleshooting for something and it's
just me not remembering how to do some
es6 thing
okay so let me I didn't get through all
the questions let's go we'll probably do
see what time it is first hmm I think
I'll do one more session of coding I'd
really like to get this working and then
we'll go go back to the live chat and
answer questions so let me start this up
one more time and let's see so I see
Joseph has said there's a max file size
option for note formidable incoming form
and is that the one we looked at
next file size
that's all I did not see the max file
size option
yeah so I'm not seeing the max file size
is am I missing it somewhere
okay so it's it's not it's not in here
yet but is it let's see can I use it
let's see
is it in there
yeah it's definitely in there nice
that's awesome
Joseph that's amazing so basically in
the documentation for formidable it does
not say anything about a max file size
option but Joseph checked out the actual
source code and found it so you can see
it here in incoming form so I don't know
why I didn't just do this right off the
bat but this is really useful to just
search an entire repository for
something so right here under max field
size there's an option for max file size
really awesome so this is cool because
this means a lot of the stuff that we
just tried to do we can just remove and
make this so much more simple so we
should be able to just follow the
implementation for the field size and
instead put file size so hopefully
that'll work let's try it out oh excuse
me host yawning all right let's get rid
of a bunch of this stuff
it's
actually let's keep this and want that
stuff
okay awesome and where's our
documentation imax file size
oops actually this way I want to be is
to stop there
so we should just be able to go form dot
max file size let's just copy this and
then change it
there we go let's put it up here
okay cool
now let's test this out so actually
probably doesn't matter we can just keep
could've just kept the ones we had but
let's make sure all right so this is
empty submit awesome check it out okay
and
all right I don't think that should have
worked maybe let's check the versions
were using
alright there's the latest version but
yes I mean this hasn't been updated in a
while so that should be in there
hmm
all right let me check so Joseph said he
saw it in a pull request that had been
merged so let me check it out
there we go
let's check out what they say not much
hmm
okay so maybe it's a little bit more
complicated it looks like
it looks like motor actually has better
better limits for this
I remember I remember we were first
looking into this we were trying to
decide between these two
Hey
okay so basically for whatever reason
this didn't work when I just did it but
even if I can't get it to work it seems
like this is not I don't it's not going
to be great for security and if the
other way that we are doing it might
actually be better but if we can do both
that would be the best
alright let's see I just saw in the live
chat ok Joseph said make it really small
that's a good idea that'll definitely
tell me if it's working or not
yeah let's make this really small so how
about this that's pretty small all right
oops should've deleted these first let's
delete them
I'm gonna delete all of them
there we go all right let's try not oh
there there okay yes it's definitely not
working
keep losing my place
hmm
that's a
okay Brett says the comment said to
check the content length in the dark
header that would be a way to reject
before downloading starts okay just so
so I guess says love you Jesse even
though you are in your left brain which
one's the left I can't remember there's
a difference between left and right ones
like more creative and but I can't
remember which ones which so which one's
the left brain supposed to be
it's
did they also so Brett okay so I guess
as left is for logic right is for pure
love and creativity
yeah oh my creativity I guess I'm I have
a little bit of creativity when I'm
doing the design stuff I saved most of
my creativity for the kitchen I like to
cook
okay Joseph says checkout issue 324 all
right let's do that
all right awesome awesome Thank You
Joseph I asked if I could talk about
myself
maybe a little a little bit after this
session so in eight minutes I'll talk
about myself a little bit if you want to
know anything specific ask it now I mean
otherwise like I guess a lot you could
talk about
all right this should not work because
when we checked file size and file began
it was always zero we can try it again
though I mean I'm gonna scroll down
obviously this is not the less the last
word on this
I'm sorry there's there's been a lot of
me reading documentation today I know
that's probably not very fun to watch I
probably should just enter this dream
after the last one and read all this
stuff on my own
oh then area yeah this is what happened
to us on file begin the file size is
zero Oh
swish some water and if we end up having
to switch I mean I guess that would be I
guess it would be okay but I'd rather
not I don't know maybe it wouldn't be a
big deal
hopefully we can find a different
solution now
okay so let's check this out
I wish this wasn't an image Wow
mm-hmm
well they have about three minutes since
this Pomodoro session is over I don't
think that we're gonna get this working
in that amount of time
all right yeah
I think I'll have to read a little bit
more try this I'm also gonna look into
using a motor see how hard it would be
to switch if the switch is easy and we
could still do everything we want then
it might take less time to just switch
than to figure out how to do this
especially if it ends up being that the
way military does it is more secure than
what we would be able to do it was
something like this so because this is a
lot of code to do what you can do in you
know a very short line with mole tears
so I have used multi before so I'm not
completely unfamiliar with it okay all
right well I'm gonna go I'm not really
gonna get much done in two minutes so
I'm just gonna go back to the live chat
and oh well sometimes that happens I
really try to get things done but we did
at least figure out we figured out a lot
of stuff didn't get everything completed
but made some good progress on
understanding how formidable works and
so hopefully I can build on a lot of
that and I think thanks for you know
everyone helping me out with that and
really finding some good stuff in the
documentation so let me go I'm gonna
scroll up a bit to where I left off
and go through some questions so so the
coding portion is done for now
if you don't want to stick around for
the question an answer that's fine thank
you so much for watching and tune in
again sometime if you can otherwise if
you have a question put it in the live
chat now I'll do my best to answer it
and if if you would rather ask it
privately you can direct message me on
Twitter or some other social media
I'm I'm pretty much on all the the main
social media channels okay so what I
leave off 312
okay so David asks do you have any
advice for beginners I'm 16 and want to
become a web so I software developer and
still deciding whether I need to go to
your university or not so let me see so
there was one at least one response I
can see to that so let me read the
response first before I I talked about
it so Mandela effect conference says if
it is paid paid for go then if you want
to try programming take nine hours a
semester and go to boot camp and then
look for an internship all four years
that you were in university yeah so
I agree saying that if it's pagan so if
you happen to get scholarships or
somehow if it's paid for then it might
not be a bad idea to go it does somewhat
depend on your situation right if for
some reason like you really need money
now then even if your school is paid for
then you still may not be able to afford
it right because there's there's other
expenses involved that sometimes that
don't get paid for and then there's the
you know all the time you spend it in
your classes you won't be able to work
or make money so there could be some
situations where even if school is paid
for you and want to but in general I
would say in majority of situations if
it's paid for you may as well do it
because it's a huge value and if you if
you take like the cost of school into
consideration you'd be making more money
doing that then you could probably make
doing anything else at that point in
your life so that said if you have to go
into debt to go to school and what you
really want to do is be a web developer
or a software developer then I don't
really recommend going to school going
to university I would recommend like
while you're already doing free code
camp so go through that I've I've read
stories of people who've gone through
free code camp and gotten jobs really
soon afterwards so that's definitely
possible I would just say work with free
code camp stuff take advantage of all
the free resources you can online do
freelance work to build up your
portfolio and apply to any job that
you're interested in just apply don't
worry if you don't meet all the
qualifications you know
know what could happen and so anyway
that's my advice I mean you're only 16
so you know at this point you're
probably in high school so you do have
some time to work on things before you
really have to decide about college you
know at least you know at least a year
or two depending on what would grade
you're in right now so you could work on
your coding and even probably pick up
some clients build your portfolio a bit
and then you'll probably have a much
better idea of of what you really want
to do hopefully that's helpful Phillips
says your videos are super realistic
that's what makes them great yeah this
is like legit reality TV here right yeah
this is a hundred percent what I
actually did the only difference between
unknowing now and what I do the rest of
the day is that I don't talk to myself
in my office when i'm not streaming and
i don't narrate what i'm doing
otherwise it's pretty much the same and
i don't have all of you helping me so
that that's another big difference
that's a benefit to me
Raphael says hello everyone hey Raphael
glad you could join I love the name
Raphael I named my first son Raphael
all right so I'm down to the bottom here
of the live chat and this is where I go
to ask me to talk about myself a little
bit okay so let me do that well let me
answer there's an easy question here
I'll answer first before I get to that
one Navan says what's the tool you used
to record sessions
it's called OBS so I think it works for
for Mac and Windows
I'm ever checked if it works on Linux or
not not sure but OBS it was fairly easy
to set up I had to mess with the
settings a little bit to get it right
but now that I have the settings right
it's pretty easy cool and Navin also
asks hi once again it's one month like
we started 100 days of code would
request you to make one session it will
be an honor for us please I'm not
exactly sure what you're asking so
request you to take one session what
sessions are so anyway Navin if you
could elaborate a little bit on your
last comment there about the 100 days of
code and everything that would be good
because I'm not exactly sure what would
you're asking all right so while I'm
waiting on the oh okay so Navin says we
do online sessions from free code camp
from the free code camp algorithms ok
cool
so
all right so let me let me know if I'm
wrong on this so is are you saying you
have basically like it would just be a
session of doing a free code camp
algorithm online
hey Brett I'll see you sir Brett's gotta
go thank you so much Brett you were like
a really big help and I really
appreciate it so hopefully I could see
you back here again okay so I'm okay
Navin that seems that seems pretty cool
could you so my length to my Twitter is
in the description could you direct
message me there with more details and
time to kind of like get a better idea
of exactly what's going on and let me
know or I mean if you if you get find me
on another social media or email or
something that works too but usually
Twitter is the most reliable way for me
to answer so just let me know let me
know some more details we could talk
about it but that sounds pretty cool I'm
definitely interested all right so I
goes let me get C to your question a bit
about myself so I just wanted to know a
little bit about me also said I will
start computer science University in a
week so good luck with that just don't
know what to expect at the Uni all right
so anyway so I'm not I'm not sure
exactly what area of my life that you
would want to know about but I guess
I'll just give you really general
general overview so I'm gonna set a
timer for five minutes
because otherwise I'll just go on and on
you all probably know by now that I can
I can talk when I get into something so
yeah so if you want to know about my my
coding journey I did a video on my own
channel about like when I first learned
to code and kind of the steps along the
way to where I am so I'm not gonna go
into that so much since you can already
watch that that's on my my
which i think is linked in the
description but basically all right
here's the basics my name is Jessie and
I I was born and raised in West Virginia
in the United States and I had I live in
Ohio now I work at a university I'm a
front-end developer I'm married I have
four kids from the ages of eight down to
nine months old not sure if that's the
information you expected but anyway yeah
I am I I do live streams now and which
is crazy because I'm normally pretty
private before I did this I really never
posted very much on social media I was
very nervous about anyone even seeing my
code if I would go to a conference
I like usually didn't talk to a lot of
people you know so it was a little it
was kind of odd and like a
spur-of-the-moment decision almost like
one day at one morning I think I had
thought about it occasionally but I
remember one morning waking up and
getting ready for work and thinking like
oh I'm gonna do this and then I just
came in and and did it like that was it
yeah so yeah so I was somewhat
introverted and I mean I mean like I'd
be fine if I didn't leave my house very
often like so not that I don't like
people I mean I love people and I
usually am fine when I'm around people
and get into it it's just the act of
actually going out to go do that do
something it's like jumping in a pool
like I don't want to jump in a pool if
it's cold but usually once you jump in
and get used to the water it's fine
that's kind of how I am with like social
situations like rather a little bit hard
for me to leave but once I'm there I'm
okay
so
yes so that's I guess a little bit about
what I'm kind of about how I am NOT on
the stream I mentioned earlier that I
really like cooking so I've worked at
restaurants before never as a chef but
just other pretty much everything else
you can do at a restaurant besides being
a chef and so I've kind of picked up so
that's kind of my other passion you know
my other hobby besides coding that I'm
really into I don't really get to do it
as often as I can because I'm usually
working but when I do get to do it it's
it's really fun I do some gaming not
really a lot
I enjoy Starcraft which is an old-school
game from the 90s not Starcraft 2 I mean
that the original Starcraft and then
otherwise I'm pretty much confined to
mobile games which I know people say
that's not really gaming but when I'm
busy and I have four kids it's like so
much easier just to play on a phone in
one hand while I'm holding a baby and
the other hand helps pass the time when
you're walking around at night trying to
put a crying baby to sleep so anyway so
I'm almost done with my five minutes of
me so obviously there's a lot more to
tell
it's just China just kind of throwing
out whatever I could think of for right
now let's see I'm 31 I don't know if
I've ever said I would I am so 31 years
old let me think
my favorite sport is American football
although I rarely ever watch it and
certainly don't play it anymore do you
think
I used to be a high school teacher I've
been a high school teacher before I've
been a manager at a fast food restaurant
I've done a lot of things I used to be a
day trader in the stock market so anyway
but five minutes is up so I know that
was kind of all over the place and
didn't necessarily have anything to do
with coding but if you want to know
about more of coding related things
about me then check out my my channel I
have at least one video about that yes
so I go said you are 31 and wow you have
four kids and you worked a lot of places
yeah I got married when I was 21 so got
started early with being married and
having kids and yeah so I jumped around
in jobs quite a bit I was only a manager
at a fast food place for a few months
and that was just not really my thing
although I got free food which was
awesome that was the best part about the
Chuck and I've worked at different
places the day trading stock burger
thing was really awesome for a while
until I lost most of my money and then
it wasn't so awesome but good thing my
wife was very patient with me whenever
that happened yeah I was a high school
teacher for a little over three years
so that was my longest the longest stay
at any job unless you count my high
school job with I worked for a city in
West Virginia called weirdin so the city
of Weirton had me I was a maintenance
person basically and I cleaned up
playgrounds I did that for like six
summers in a row so anyway I've gone
over my time so I'm gonna I'm gonna stop
now if anyone if anyone wants me to do
that again just let me know
in the in the live chat so I try to keep
it centered on code mostly since this is
free code camp but I'm not opposed to a
few minutes of talking about me only if
you're really interested otherwise I'm
not gonna definitely not going to do it
so anyway I guess I thank you you're
welcome no problem all right so I think
I've answered all the questions and
let's see yeah I think sorry I'm just
just checking my calendar on my other
screen to see make sure I can stream at
the same time tomorrow
actually yeah tomorrow might be a little
bit different time for a stream mm-hmm
it might be a morning in am stream
eastern time so I'll try to get in early
and let you all know as soon as I can
because I have I have to do an interview
for a candidate for a web developer
position that we have open right around
the same time I normally stream so I
don't really want to risk it and if that
goes longer than expected then I won't
be able to stream so probably plan on
doing a stream tomorrow morning eastern
time maybe like 10:00 a.m. somewhere
around there Eastern but so I'll see
y'all then hopefully I can get some of
this figured out that we worked on today
and let you know how it went but anyway
thank you so much for watching and for
all your help
I really appreciate that and I'll be
back tomorrow
have a great day